segundo entonces la posibilidad de
investigar de forma independiente lo que
pasó el 6 de enero en el capitolio se
necesitaban 60 votos
hace unos días se tenían esos 60 votos
porque tanto republicanos como
demócratas iban a votar a favor de este
panel de investigación pero por
influencia de mitch mcconnell el líder
de la minoría republicana pues no se
logró estos 60 votos esta mayoría
necesaria en el senado para que se
aprobara este panel según mitch
mcconnell este panel de investigación no
iba a aportar nada nuevo a lo que ya se
conocía ni tampoco iba a sanar las
heridas que pues se dejó este atentado
al capitolio el 6 de enero sin embargo
la familia de los policías las familias
estaban pidiendo que se aclare que se
investigue y esa posición de las
familias es la que llevó a demócratas y
a los pocos republicanos a votar para
aprobar este panel de investigación sin
embargo los republicanos terminaron
votando en
y lo que están diciendo analistas es que
lo terminaron hundiendo esta posibilidad
de investigación precisamente para
proteger el partido republicano de cara
a las elecciones legislativas del 2022
ahora a cristóbal cambiamos de tema
porque el presidente de iovine también
presentó el nuevo presupuesto fiscal
para el próximo año que abarca este plan
de gasto y en cuanto se calcula que
podría quedar endeudado el gobierno si
se aprueba este presupuesto para el 2022
si es un nivel de gasto para el 2022 de
6 billones de dólares sería el nivel de
gasto más alto en eeuu desde la segunda
guerra mundial les recordemos que hay un
gran gasto gran presencia por parte del
gobierno es algo que quiere yo vaivén
recuperar más gasto público por parte
del gobierno para reactivar la economía
que ha sido afectada por la pandemia
este gasto de 6 billones de dólares
incluye entonces dos temas el primero el
plan en infraestructura un plan que
incluye renovar vías férreas renovar
carreteras aeropuertos puertos y hacer
la transición a la economía verde con
mucha inversión en cambio climático y el
segundo parte de este este presupuesto
es el tema de agrandar la presencia del
estado en un plan de empleo y también en
un plan de familias para recuperar la
clase media estadounidense
cristóbal gracias por información feliz
resto de noche